[Musique]
quelques journalistes entoure ce matin
là la chorégraphe de la cph de sainte
marie je les félicite et en tout cas je
vais aller vers eux et voilà puis leur
dire merci et bravo merci parce que il
m'apporte beaucoup au quotidien cette
c'est ces ateliers en y danse il
m'apporte beaucoup
bravo parce que cette fois ci cette
année ils sont partis en autonomie par
rapport à l'année dernière c'est une
grande avancée parce que cette pratique
handidanse
elle amène les personnes porteuses
handicap vers l'autonomie
jamais ces deux danseurs porteurs de
handicap d'arriver à un tel accueil
seuls 700 participants au concours il
termine à la première place et remporte
même de la médaille de la chorégraphie
la plus festive
ça représente beaucoup de travail
[Musique]
beaucoup de volonté volontariat ces
missions de chacun de nous donnons aussi
quand on voit ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire capable de réaliser
vous vous rendez pas compte une personne
en situation de handicap en fauteuil
roulant par exemple qui fait qu'ils dont
ce qui fait danser son fauteuil
mais si jamais plus en moi et ça là ça
nous donne un exemple et on se dit
content de nous plaindre
dans un coin la famille attentionné
observent la scène
le bonheur est communicatif la mise dans
ce qu'il est sa porte des bonnets a dit
bonnaire et je suis fier aussi pour le
vin d'ailleurs agents et aux aidants se
tend même à la maison et danse et la
musique et danse même c'est pour la
musique dit danse vais fêter ça comment
ben là c'est soit c'est champagne la
danse un très bon moyen pour
vous exprimer c'est se donner à fond
c'est la fausse cette voie et là
franchement là vraiment je trouve ça
excellent prochaine étape pour landed
ans le concours régional qui sera
organisé en novembre un moment où la
danse prend encore exercer sa magie